[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here okay so
iphone
gates the gate suffix is sometimes used
paired with a noun to refer to a scandal
of some kind of course best known by
watergate which was a political scandal
and so the iphone gates every year are
used to dramatically refer to pretty
much literally any problem the iphone
has at all like if anyone finds anything
with the iphone that may be
unintentional or any sort of problem in
any way or may affect the user in a way
that wasn't supposed to
you got yourself a gate you get to name
it so there's chip gate there's ben gate
antennagate beauty gate charge gate u2
gate we get a pretty constant flow of
gates i would say every year when the
new iphone comes out then again that's
because we have a crew of people for
sure looking for them every september as
soon as the iphone gets announced and
released we're on it uh and for good
reason it gets a lot of people talking
about it so the reason these are such a
big deal is because of the massive
massive scale of the iphone now we know
smartphones do have problems sometimes
quality control is a thing so that's a
big part of the reason why we have
warranty programs and insurance programs
and apple care that's a big reason why
these things exist sometimes things do
go wrong and you have to be able to hold
that company who did that thing wrong
accountable for it so in the fiscal year
of 2017 from beginning to end apple sold
216
million
iphones
that is
so many phones but with that kind of
success and i kind of scale comes the
fact that if you have a small mistake in
0.01
of those iphones that you shipped
whether it's manufacturing or quality
control or some slip intolerances that
will affect
21
600 iphones in fact if they forget a
part in literally i did the math on this
0.001 percent of iphones just some issue
and that many that's still more than 2
000 problems that apple has to deal with
so pretty much any problem we find with
the new iphone no matter how small
basically has to be treated as a large
potentially really important issue
because of how many people it might
affect so the two main gates we've
gotten this year have been in 2018
beauty gate and charge gate you may have
heard of either one of these beauty gate
affects potentially everyone who ever
takes a selfie and cares about that
selfie at all on the new iphones and
charge gate we don't really know how
many people it affects so beauty gate
refers to this extra skin smoothing
effect that seems to be happening with
the image processing from the iphone
10s's front-facing camera similar to
what you might find in a beauty mode in
another phone many people are noticing
this it's not even an issue or a glitch
necessarily like it's happening with
everyone's iphones it's more just like
very unlike apple apple usually has the
more realistic front-facing cameras they
avoid distortion they avoid color
shifting they've long been the standard
for selfie takers around the world they
can depend on that iphone to show you
exactly what you look like without any
crazy beauty filters but yet this year
as we've seen with the iphone 10s it
does we do have a little bit of that
skin smoothing effect
it just doesn't seem like very apple
like they wouldn't put a worse camera in
the new iphone would they apple wouldn't
do that right then the other one charge
gate is actually more serious and i
think it's best explained by lou's video
who went much more in depth with it and
testing it and going through all the
explanations but basically there's a
bunch of versions of this the most
common one is that when some iphone 10s
or 10s maxes are in standby and you plug
them in
they don't start to charge until you
wake them up then they start charging
it's a strange behavior and this might
not even be a big deal to you if you
usually like wake up the phone while
you're charging it anyway but there
again is that chance like if you're
affected you might just toss the phone
on the charger for a night and come back
in an hour before you need to go out and
you wake it up and it didn't charge at
all and you're about to die and you have
to leave that's the type of situation
you're looking at that's kind of a
problem so naturally when we see that we
kind of wonder well am i affected what
are the chances it's pretty easy to test
if you're affected but how many iphones
are affected by this and turns out if
you look at lou's video it makes it look
like a bunch of them potentially now
something to note for people wondering
why i didn't cover these in depth or why
i didn't do a dedicated video on each
one of these or something like that um
it's not because i'm sponsored by apple
or something you know that's illegal
right it's just really that it wasn't a
huge deal to me charge gate hasn't
affected any of my devices trust me i've
checked and the beauty face smoothing or
whatever for whatever reason isn't as
harsh on darker faces it's more of just
like an exaggerated hdr effect it's
different it's very unlike apple but it
wasn't really that insane to me this is
something that i think can easily be
fixed with a software update
plus i'm not a huge selfie taker anyway
so i guess it just kind of slipped by my
radar but the real reason these gates
always turn into such a big deal is
pretty much always
how apple responds to them how apple
handles these gates they're pretty much
known for
not really handling it like they will
steer away as far away from
acknowledging it as a problem as
possible
and just sort of make a statement about
how
maybe we're using it wrong i'm sorry
what you were you were holding the phone
in a way that covers the antenna bands
and makes the signal look like it drops
oh that's fine that's just just don't
hold the phone like that you're holding
it wrong that's what it was oh what's
that the big phone is literally bending
in people's pockets oh no no that's just
that's your pants really shouldn't be
that tight actually it's more of a
feature letting you know that than a bug
wait have you have you read have you
actually looked at the official apple
statement about the iphone 4 antennagate
it's kind of incredible i'm going to
link it below just because it's worth
another read in 2018. it basically went
along lines of dear iphone users iphone
4 is totally the best smartphone ever
first of all it also has the best
antennas ever we got some reports that
if you hold it a certain way it drops
the displayed bars of service but hey
look any smartphone will do this so
we're gonna push a software update that
stops the iphone from erroneously
displaying less bars than other phones
in conclusion nothing to see here iphone
4s again is the best phone ever thank
you very much like i'm kind of expecting
an apple statement about this new iphone
10s charging problem charge gate
sometime soon just because it seems like
a legitimate issue
but it'll probably be along the same
lines like it'll probably go something
like dear iphone users iphone 10s and
10s max are clearly the best smartphones
ever and they're our best-selling small
and big iphone yet just fyi we became
aware of of a certain charging behavior
that affects a small number of iphone
users this behavior it's different but
it's it's definitely more still of a
feature than a bug but we'll be pushing
a software update uh to just change that
behavior in the future in case you guys
want it that way again iphone 10s is
clearly the best phone yet by the way it
also has the best battery life we've
ever shipped thank you from apple please
keep buying these phones and look at the
end of the day
people still keep buying iphones for
sure apple has some of the absolute best
customer loyalty of any company in the
world among anything which is impressive
and we just kind of hold apple to a high
standard at this point but that's not
super uncommon if you look back and
remember when samsung had galaxy note 7s
literally exploding in people's pockets
they're actually endangering the lives
of their owners in various places
started getting banned at establishments
for safety reasons you couldn't fly with
them they were illegal to sell or buy
anywhere for any reason i mean this is
crazy for a smartphone samsung offered a
trade-in program where they reported 95
of those trade-ins went on and got
another samsung phone so you can bet
iphone users after a little beauty gate
a little bit of charge gate
they're gonna chance it again with
another iphone they'll probably be back
but as always there will be entire
channels and and reports dedicated to
sifting through the new iphone and many
other phones as soon as they're released
looking for any possibility of any new
issues and as they should because not
only does it make the juiciest most
clickable headlines but also kind of
forces apple or whatever companies
involved to respond
and to fix it
and for that the products get better
and we all win so
thanks gates
talk to you guys the next one
peace